Luke O'Connor was only 19. a business
study student in his second year at
Manchester Metropolitan University but
at 2AM on Wednesday morning Luke was
fatally stabbed heading home from a
night out in a statement Luke's family
said our Lively bubbly beautiful boy has
been taken from us and our family are
now left with a hole in our hearts that
will never be filled
the attack happened in an area of
Manchester full of student pubs clubs
and takeaways that were open at the time
it was just meters from University
accommodation this Photograph shared
exclusively with Sky News was taken in
the immediate aftermath it shows groups
of young people crowded around the
police Cordon as emergency teams
searched the scene I'd been inside the
pub with my meds and we walked out and
there was police everywhere and there
was people in like bad States and stuff
like that and they normally they knew
what had happened at the time we could
see a knife on the floor it's not nice
happening on your doorstep yeah it's a
really sad time for the people of the
area I couldn't imagine what the
families and friends of the of the of
the poor by the um it happened to her
feeling great amount as the police have
now introduced a section 64 this
immediate area that means that it gives
them additional powers to stop and
search anyone for that temporary time
they say they know that can make people
worried but they say they're doing it to
keep people safe
because students here are frightened I'd
say a lot of students are feeling very
unsettled like particularly even just
living around the corner we're like
taking more precautions to lock our
doors lock our Windows no one's getting
buses anymore
police call this a terrible crime Luke's
families say they want Justice to be
served for their beautiful young son
robbed of Life Katarina vatozi Sky News
in Manchester